hello and welcome to this intelligent
squared online debate about whether or
not Britain should send the Parn and
marbles back to Greece if you're joining
us live you're in luck as you get to
vote on the issue I'm going to ask you
to do that right now so that we can just
gauge where opinion is um before we hear
from our guests tonight so please vote
now for the motion
uh the Parn and marbles should be sent
back to Greece if you agree please click
on agree uh if you disagree do the same
and if you're not sure please click on
undecided before we start I'm just going
to explain briefly how tonight will work
out um in a moment we'll hear from our
two Debaters who are going to make their
opening speeches and then I'll chare a
little debate between the two of them
but I will make sure that we have time
for your questions so please please do
send them in for either speaker or both
but here we are just freshly in um for
the motion the part and marbles should
be sent back to Greece as things stand
we have 81% of you fall just 177%
against and 2%
undecided so that's quite um that's
quite a decisive vote so far but let's
see how the the evening pans out um I
want to Begin by uh inviting our first
speaker to to join us this is Ed VY Lord
VY of didcot who's a former conservative
government Minister who was in charge of
culture and digital M Matters from 2010
to 2016 becoming the longest serving
minister in that role he's now an
adviser to a number of companies Tech
funds and Tech startups he writes and
broadcasts regularly on politics and
culture and he presents his own show on
times radio every Friday evening which I
can't recommend enough uh Ed please do
make your opening
argument uh thanks uh very much manven
uh that is obviously a terrible uh
result in the ballot that intelligence
square has just conducted because the
only way is down for me is such a
resounding early Victory can only go
horribly uh wrong and I have debated uh
nol on this topic before and I know uh
how articulate and forceful
uh he will be in his uh arguments I uh
came on board something called the
patham project about two years ago which
is a campaign to reunify the parnon
sculptures but it's an enlightened
campaign with um lots of opportunities
for both sides both the British uh and
the Greeks going forward uh as culture
Minister I'm afraid I took the very
traditional position of arguing that the
pathon and sculptures belong to the
British Museum and the Greeks should
have nothing nothing to do with them and
I fell for the seductive arguments of
the then director of the British museum
uh Ian McGregor uh who talked about the
British museum being a world Museum and
that more people could see the PN and
sculptures in the British Museum and
also compare them to other civilizations
but once I was free from the constraints
of government and uh started to think
more deeply about the subject I've come
to the resounding conclusion which only
becomes more forceful uh with every
debate I have that um The Return of the
pathon and sculptures is is an
unanswerable case but also a huge
opportunity for all the different sides
involved I think when we talk about the
pathon sculptures we're talking about
the freeze that surrounded uh the paonan
and what we're really talking about is
the
reunification of a unique piece of art
the parnum freeze is like a a scene from
a movie it's a huge procession a
celebration procession and it has been
rent aunder and split into uh half of it
or what remains of it half of it remains
in Athens and half of it sits uh in the
British uh Museum and the time has now
come to reunite this unique piece of
work and also to reunite it in the place
where it was created uh and first as it
were exhibited in Athens it's time to
see the whole thing as it is as it
survives and once you've looked at it to
be able to look out of the window and
see the Acropolis uh where it first um
appeared
um I think that it's important to state
that the patham project has some very
thoughtful views on how this could be
achieved it does for example uh talk
about the potential of setting up an
independent trust which could own the
path sculptures so you could as it were
Park the ownership question of whether
it should be returned to Greece or stay
in the ownership of the British museum
which so often diverts the argument and
that trust itself could raise money it
could raise money for scholarship it
could fund student
bseries uh and it could become a very
exciting effectively uh shared Endeavor
between the British uh and the Greeks
who in all other circumstances uh do
rather like each other and enjoy each
other's culture and civilization it's
also the case that um the Greek
government has indicated it's not
official policy but it's indicated that
where the British museum to move on this
issue the opportunity to take some
iconic objects from Athens and exhibit
them in the British museum uh would
present itself so far from losing the
sculptures as it were the British museum
would gain access to a treasure Trove of
exhibits which you could regularly
display in the British museum to the
delectation of all its
visitors there are obviously lots of
arguments against returning the parnon
sculptures that n Malcolm and others who
take his view uh regularly POS it the
most obvious argument is that the uh PA
sculptures were legitimately acquired by
Lord Elgen uh it was a straightforward
contract they were purchased just like
you would purchase a tisan uh or a
rembrand and there you have it I very
much doubt that the purchase was in any
way legal but it was certainly in many
respects under Jess it was made with the
occupying ottoman forces it was made by
a man who was the British Ambassador at
a time when the Turks wanted British
support uh arguably the agreement even
with the Turkish author ities was simply
to sketch and draw uh the sculptures not
to forcibly remove them when they were
removed uh many of them were damaged uh
and indeed the original intention of
Lord Elgen of course was to display them
in his own estate the only reason they
came into the possession of the British
museum was because Lord Elgen went
bankrupt uh and he also wanted an
English peerage uh and that is the
reason why they ended up in uh the
British museum by Dent of an act of
Parliament and of course at the time it
was still highly controversial and
wildly uh debated at the time it wasn't
a uh unanimous view of the British
public at the time that we were right to
acquire them there is also an argument
which I find profoundly patronizing
which is still used to this day which
somehow depicts the Greeks as somehow
not capable of looking after their own
uh Heritage it's often uh the point is
made that there was an explosion at the
crolis when the venetians were storing
ammunition there that happened about 150
years before Lord Elgen acquired uh the
sculptures and in any event the
sculptures that he so kindly Left Behind
did survive and find there themselves in
the Acropolis uh Museum a
state-of-the-art modern museum where
they are extremely well cared for and
it's certainly not the case that the
British museum looked after the
sculptures when they acquired them uh
the notorious fraudster and arts dealer
duen who after whom the galleries in
which the parnon sculptures reside is
named uh had them scrubbed clean freshly
white uh in order to be displayed and in
my view they're not particularly well
displayed uh in any event and there's
certainly no uh question that the
British museum can be regarded as having
been a careful Steward of the sculptures
they have uh we know that the British
museum has been in the news uh recently
uh because of the of many uh artifacts I
would not run this argument as another
argument to return the Parn and
sculptures but I would say uh perhaps
that people in glass houses shouldn't
throw stones and the argument that
somehow the Greeks are not capable of
looking after their own Heritage I think
is severely weakened uh if it's made by
a museum that hasn't necessarily shown
that it is capable of caring uh for its
own collection so I'm not going to use
that against the British museum but
equally I hope that argument will now be
properly uh dropped another odd argument
that is sometimes used and it's used was
used by David Cameron when he was asked
about this and it's often used by uh
other Prime Ministers who are always
doorstepped about this issue uh is that
this would be the start of a slippery uh
slope uh that uh somehow all museums
would be denuded of their collections uh
a good comparison would be the VNA which
is very prominent in this issue of
restitution which says it's received
nine restitution claims uh uh for its
2.7 million objects that it has in its
possession nine restitution claims in
the last 20 years but the restitution
issue is extremely easy to deal with you
s you simply set up an independent
committee that can give advice to
museums which doesn't need to be binding
on any uh restitution claim that they uh
receive we do for Nazi art we have the
spoliation committee which quite rightly
looks at the provenance of art that may
have been acquired uh illegally by the
Nazis we do it we have the reviewing
committee for the export of works of art
which quite rightly uh stops objects
which are deemed to be uh inherent to
British culture from being exported if a
public collection can raise the money to
uh purchase them and that is also a
clinching argument for the parnon
sculptures if it's okay for us to set up
a committee that recognizes that there
are objects in this country which are
inherently part of our culture we must
therefore accept the argument that there
are some objects in our Museum which are
inherently tie to the culture of other
countries including Nations as friendly
as uh as the Greeks the paron sculptures
are a pretty unique uh issue uh the
Greeks have been asking for them back
since Independence for some 200 years
the Greeks have asked politely for those
these objects to be returned they need
to be
reunited with their brothers and sisters
in the Acropolis Museum the surviving
elements of the pathon and freeze need
to be seen as one unified work of art in
the place where they were created in the
place where they were displayed and a
museum that is worthy of them uh uh
supervised by a government that is a
worthy keeper of them uh with the
opportunity for the British and the
Greeks to work together on scholarship
and support for this unique cultural
object
thank you Lord fazey for putting forward
the argument for why we should be
sending the Parn and marbles back to
Greece uh and also describing so well
the clarity that comes from leaving
government um I'd now like to call on
our second guest tonight to oppose the
motion uh and I'm delighted that we're
joined by s s NL Malcolm who couldn't
have got a better write up than he did
from Ed FY there um but who was a senior
research fellow at All Souls College
Oxford he's a former political columnist
and foreign editor of The Spectator and
his recent Publications include a book
about human rights law and the
philosophy of Human Rights a history of
Western ideas about the Ottoman Empire
and an account of Ali pasha's diplomacy
during the Napoleonic Wars so a complete
polymath and we're delighted he can join
us well thank you manine for those kind
words and indeed thank you Ed um
couple of very general points to begin
with uh I know some people have a sort
of principled objection to the phrase
Elan marbles um I will use it from time
to time I'm not trying to rile anyone
it's just the traditional phrase and
sometimes it's convenient to know that
we're talking about the Elgen marbles in
the British museum not path and
sculptures generally which are in London
there in Athens and there are some
scattered around other museums as well
so I may mostly call them the marbles
the other General point is just I'm
aware that particularly in recent years
this issue has been rather hyped up into
a sort of culture wars issue and I just
want to say I really don't approach it
in that spirit it's a complicated issue
there are uh not least important
historical issues that need to be
addressed there are various matters of
principle that arise um I don't see this
as something on which which the forces
of good on one side I know plenty of
very reasonable people who disagree with
me and there are arguments on the other
side uh that I've taken note of
carefully I think just under the surface
there may be some deeper divisions of
people's assumptions perhaps nowadays
about the role of the so-called
Universal museums and perhaps also more
generally about attitudes to the distant
past to perceived wrongs and the sense
of what we should do about them and if I
have time I'll touch on both of those I
think they are important but I don't
don't see people who disagree even on
those things as automatically enemies in
a culture world so I said there were
historical issues the first is the basic
one which is the foundation of the Greek
government's view um on all their
official um statements they say this was
theft and um Ed has rather supported
that um questioning whether Elgen got
any sort of proper permission uh he also
said Elgen purchased them but that's not
true there was no purchase from the
automs he got permission to remove
Stones uh from the
Acropolis we have a contemporary
translation of that official document
it's quite clear that it allowed him to
remove Stones uh he cooperated with the
local authorities in Athens he had to he
had to hire hundreds of men at some
point and taking them down to the port
at peras uh this was all done in plain
view and the otoman authorities allowed
it to happen uh it sometimes said and I
think Ed touched on this too that
perhaps he went beyond the terms of the
permission he was only permitted to draw
uh take moldings and so no he actually
got written permission to take away some
stones and he did
so now of course the immediate response
to that is well so what permission from
the Ottomans I think had used the phas
the occupiers uh
Invaders well we're in 1801 when this
story starts and they were Invaders in
this part of Greece in about
1458 so we're talking about an
absolutely settled State 350 years um
it's not as if you know they're
occupying a Greek State there was no
function in Greek State when they
arrived what they replaced was ruled by
so-called Frankish I Western European
feudal Lords who were were Catholics and
uh had a very different culture from the
Greeks and then before those you go back
to the Byzantine Empire there was not a
functioning Greek state that you could
say oh this was occupied and you should
have got their permission if you say
well you should get the permission of
the Greek Community but how would you do
that in 1801 in Athens U there's no
constitutional way of doing that there
are Community leaders called arons and
they did cooperate with elin's Workman
uh one of them admittedly he was British
Consul at the time but um there's no
record of them objecting uh to this
whole process as it went on year after
year and the person with the greatest
moral Authority for the Greek Community
one might say their representative was
the Archbishop the Orthodox Archbishop
and he was happy to co cooperate with
elin's men and he even volunteered his
Services finding ancient in his eyes
Pagan sculptures for
them so that's the first historical
point the second is you need to think of
the pathon rather differently from the
way you think of it today it was a
massive ruin much much more ruined than
it is today a lot of what you see now is
the result of
reconstruction um columns put up in the
1840s big reconstruction in the early
20th century it was as Ed said blown
apart by a massive explosion in 1687 it
was actually the Ottomans who had the
the gunpowder there and the venetians
who said off with a well unlucky shot
massive explosion a lot of the
sculptures were destroyed on the spot
many were blown off the building uh
partly shattered some were in
recognizable bits they lay in rubble uh
and when Elgen got there you had this
ruin with bits still falling off
sometimes dropping off in storms and
some of the sculptures he obtained were
dug up from the rubble where Greek
stonemasons were often just taking bits
of sculptures and melting them down into
lime or chopping up bits of them in
order to make ordinary houses in in
Athens so he was actually saving
sculptures from destruction that's a
fundamental point and that was his
principal motive um the we have the
evidence of the rate of Destruction and
it's shocking just very briefly in the
middle of the 18th century so for 52
years before his men arrived there were
12 large sculpted figures on the western
end of the
parnon by the time his men arrived there
were four in just 52 years I mean that's
a massive rate of
disruption um and on top of that there
were Muslims taking pot shots at figures
uh there were people casually defacing
sculpted figures um and there were
tourists now who uh would U buy little
bits and pieces to take home as
souvenirs and his men were shocked by
that told him and so he used the
permission he'd got to the maximum to
take away as much as he could I feel I'm
very close to my time limit to but just
to touch on the two deeper issues I
[Music]
mentioned Ed was rather casual in his
dismissal of the idea of a universal
Museum um brushing aside the defense of
it by Neil
McGregor I think there is a lot to be
said for a universal or encyclopedic
Museum that presents people with World
culture across the Great civilizations
and the British museum is one of those
par exelor there's more we could say
about that but I think what he called
the pointless slippery slope argument it
hasn't applied to a lot of the
particular things that other museums
have sent back to their Origins so far
but anything as massive and headline
grabbing as the uh Elgen marbles would I
think have a large effect and the other
General point and then I'll stop is
about our attitude to the past and it's
difficult to capture this just in a few
soundbite sentences but when I read in
the newspaper and it was in the
newspaper yesterday about um a Jewish
Family whose paintings were confiscated
and stolen by the Nazis finally getting
them back my blood boils with
indignation that you know they've had to
wait so long to get this this was
monstrous theft by a monstrous regime
anyway we can all feel deep human
indignation about that but when I go to
the lou in Paris and I look at some of
the great paintings stolen by Napoleon's
troops from Italy and never sent back at
the end to the war my blood does not
boil does that mean I'm hyp hypocrite no
I think I'm actually giving the standard
reaction which is the deeper you go into
the past the more differently you have
to think about these things of course it
was wrong at the time I'm not saying it
was less wrong because it was a long
time ago but the rights and claims that
are generated by that wrong gradually
change and fade over time if they didn't
we would all be stuck uh trying to do
compensation for Wars centuries ago and
all kinds of things that we disapprove
of so I'm just touching on that perhaps
some of these larger issues will come up
in the discussion thank you s Malcolm
for setting out the history behind this
problem um so well we're now going to
open up the debate so please do send in
your questions um before we get to the
audience's questions though um I just
wanted to very quickly pick up um
firstly sonol uh you pointed out the the
difficulty of the situation in Athens
when these marbles were were brought to
Britain how a lot of the marbles were
being broken up there was line was being
broken up to' be used for for homes um
there wasn't really a state to ask for
permission obviously the situation is
very different now there is a state
there is a a very good way of knowing
where re public opinion is uh and we
also know there is a a massive museum is
the argument now not very different for
why we should be sending them back
well there is certainly a Greek State
now obviously um since the
1830s and um that state as I said at the
beginning makes as the foundation of its
position on this issue the claim that
Elan simply stole the marbles they they
really do emphasize that you know just
recently well several times this year
we've had official statements from the
Greek Ministry of culture so I'm not
wandering off into some sort of bypass
in the in the distant past by by saying
that is wrong it's fundamental to their
argument now people have said well For
Heaven's Sake if only Elgen had waited
um by by the
1830s the problem would have disappeared
and then there was a Greek state it
would care about the pathon as it did
but he couldn't predict that nobody
could have predicted that they would
have thought that the Ottoman Empire
could last for another hundred years
which it did in other parts of the
Balkans um so that was you know none of
this changes the reasonableness of what
he did on your question about the the
situation being different now well yes
of course um in response to Ed I would
say I don't think anyone now uses the
argument oh the Greeks can't look after
archaeological exhibits or statues and
so um and certainly it's true that until
the new Acropolis Museum was built it
was not unreasonable to say well but
they wouldn't have a proper Museum to
put them in because the old Acropolis
Museum was very small it couldn't really
take you know this huge quantity and
display them properly now that problem
has gone away so nobody I think is
saying oh the Greeks can't look after
these things um but the arguments never
rested simply on the claim that they
couldn't or that they didn't have room
they rest on a wide range of issues and
I've only just touched on a few of them
but if if as you say there wasn't
actually a purchase and this was much
more a caretaker arrangement of making
sure the marbles were well looked after
and on display elsewhere is it not now
time to stop the caretaker
role well caretaker in a sense
for how would it have been put at the
time for Western Civilization I mean the
the reason why people valued Ancient
Greek art was it was seen as
foundational to Western
civilization um and this is not
irrelevant either if we're talking about
the creation of Greek State Greece got
in first with massive help from Western
Powers long before other states were
thought worth supporting even though
they were Christian I mean would be
states in the in the Osan Empire why
because the educated classes people like
Elgen had been brought up on the
classics and they were Phil helin they
they were just you know Greek lovers
with an idea of the importance of this
so This contributed to the existence of
a Greek State he was exemplifying that
himself and Ed um no made a very
compelling argument there about the idea
of having a universal Museum about being
able to display different eras in human
history alongside each other is is there
not something in that as as the man who
used to be in charge of museums here um
It's A Hard argument to to be
against uh it is a hard argument to be
against it's one that the British museum
uses and indeed argues that many more
countries are now getting into the game
of the universal Museum I think that um
the British museum is stuffed the gills
uh with Greek artifacts the idea that it
couldn't display uh objects that
illustrate the genius of ancient Greek
civilization if it didn't have the Elgen
marbles or pathon and sculptures is
utterly uh ludicrous and what we're
talking about as I say it's very
important to focus on the objects
themselves to reunify it's called
reunification for a reason it's
reunifying two pieces of a seamless
piece of art which have been unjustly
torn asunder and the idea that you
couldn't wander into the British museum
in the future and see some incredible
objects uh is for the birds but it's
also worth reminding people that pathon
project itself wants a win-win it's the
first time as it were the Greeks in
general have said if we can uh get the
pathon sculptures reunited in the place
where they be created we would recognize
that as a hugely magnanimous gesture and
return in in return we would uh lend
some of the iconic objects that you
would see in the Acropolis Museum today
to uh the British Museum and we've gone
further at the parom project to say uh
that there should be a sort of joint
stewardship some continued British uh
involvement in the care and scholarship
around the parnon sculptures but the
British museum will always be a
universal Museum Museum regardless of
whether it retains the parnon
sculptures you talk about reunification
of these sculptures uh and how they've
been unjustly torn
aunder is there an argument though that
in a way that has now become a part of
their history you know we see great
monuments that have been destroyed by
all damaged by walls that have followed
many many many centuries later and you
still preserve sometimes the damage that
has been done because it records another
era of History how how do you how do you
get around that with the path and
Marvels do they do they not have a
chapter now which belongs to Britain
they do have a chapter to belong to
Britain which is why we are proposing
this uh sort of independent trust which
would have British uh involvement and we
do recognize that the pathon and
sculptures have played an important part
in uh British history and what nol talks
about in terms of uh Phil helenismo on
and the uh importance of classical
architecture uh in in Britain but um as
I say this is a unique work of art which
deserved to be seen the original work of
art to be seen in its
entirety uh in one place and that should
be uh in Athens uh but that does not
mean that we can't recognize the role
the sculptures have played in uh British
history so I I do just want to address a
couple of points that NL did make as
well the the one that sort of drives me
slightly around the bend is this
depiction of kind of crazed locals kind
of taking pot
shots at the Acropolis because it goes
back to my opening argument if no was
right about that there wouldn't be any
paron sculptures left in Happ it's quite
obvious that he's exaggerating uh this
kind of ludicrous scene of people trying
to sort of smash the only people who
vandalized uh directly the sculptur were
Lord Elgen and his band of merry men who
literally tore them hacked them hacked
them off the side of the Acropolis many
of which some of which fell to the
ground and were smashed it's also
completely untrue to say that the firm
and the warrant gave Elgen permission to
remove them it's quite clear from the
translation that Elgen had permission uh
to Grub around in the ground and pick up
objects he did not have permission to
Chisel them off the side of the building
and I also take great issue with no
depicting this kind of sort of
bureaucratic European Union Style
importation certificate as Lord Elgen
trundled them down to the harbor you
know the idea that a few bribes weren't
uh finding their way into the hands of
the watching Turks is uh again utterly
ludicrous you know all the vat and
import charges were being paid uh it was
quite clear what he was up to and he
wanted to display them in his country or
state where none of us would have seen
them if he hadn't gone
bankrupt no do you want to come back on
that how did you guess yes um the punch
hot I'm not making up things there are
witnesses at the time who described this
and I'm not talking so much about craz
locals I'm talking about janissaries who
were peasant soldiers in the why we got
any Parn and sculptures left um I'm
talking about a musket shot I'm not you
know these things were quite high up on
a wall um these you know we have
descriptions of this there's a lot of
damage to the ones that remained now we
don't we we can't get ballistics experts
to tell us how much of that was by
muskets fired by janisar for fun how
much of it by the bombardment of the
Acropolis by Greek forces in 1821 when
they were lobbing mortar shells into the
Acropolis uh on a daily basis or how
much by the bombardment by the Ottomans
in 1826 to 1827 when theopolis was under
bombardment for nearly a year um but we
do know from witnesses that this was
happening secondly on the Fairman I'm
sorry that we have the wording of the
Fairman in the Contemporary Italian
translation by a professional translator
in istano at the time and it doesn't say
you can only take bits of stone that
were found in the ground it doesn't
specify where the bits of stone came
from it just says you can take bits of
stone away and finally on taking things
I don't know where this all this EU vat
stuff comes from I don't think it arises
from anything I said um but you used you
threw in the word bribes we've known
since 1816 that bribes were used because
that's discussed in the select committee
report of the House of Commons um this
was how things were done in the otoman
Empire he couldn't have got his men in
at the beginning just to make drawings
without paying bribes to the military
commander of the Fortress so there's
nothing um particularly shock shocking
about that it was just normality I'm
afraid is that a process you feel
entirely comfortable with the bribes the
the permission from the British
Council the no the British ccil wasn't
giving permission I mean he wasn't in a
position to do that but he was
cooperating as so far as we can tell
were the other arons and very strongly
the Archbishop do I feel comfortable
about bribery is is that is that a
legitimate vote from the from the Greek
people if one of the people consulted
was the British
Council um he was one of the archons of
the city I mean I was just saying at
that point in my introduction how in
what possible way would we say well what
represent the community well it had
these the small number of community
leaders called arams and it had an
Archbishop I was saying we we don't know
you know they weren't writing Diaries we
can't get into their heads very far but
all the evidence we have suggests that
they cooperated and we do know that the
Archbishop cooperated very
strongly